Jim asks what's your opinion on the auto
reply DM services Jim I really wanted to
take this question because I'm so glad
you did it and asked it and I appreciate
it and I want to say that I hate it it
is literally the thing that I despise
the most I have actively unfollowed many
of you because I followed you and you
did that and I unfollowed because it
speaks to the intent you have on the
platform which is to use it as a
conversion mechanism you're looking to
scale social media in a world where
social media especially on Twitter is
not scalable if you haven't figured out
why I over indexed it on the platform
it's because it's a non scalable
platform when done right because Twitter
is the only true social network
everything else has evolved into content
push this is the one place we all talk
in a Town Square environment and we can
jump into each other's conversations and
it is not creepy and when you go
auto-reply in a town square you're the
guy walking around the office and you're
just handing people your business card
without saying hello and nobody likes
that guy or gal at a conference or
networking event but blindly just
handing a card without even really
engaging I think it's a terrible move I
think it turns off a lot of people I
think even if people don't untie me I
haven't because I'm just busy and I
haven't you think you got my follow or
something good happened it's the wrong
move all you had to do was engage with
the people that followed you twice for
about six minutes which is time I'm not
saying it's not but you could have
gotten to depth you're looking for so
what I'm gonna sign up for your
newsletter and you're gonna email me and
it's gonna go to spam I'm not gonna
engage because the first taste that you
have of someone
the initial context that first moment
that first impression when it's you've
lost oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe